[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing three major
differences between the book and film
versions of hermione granger of course
if you know even a little about the
wizarding world of harry potter you know
or at least have heard of the name
hermione granger one of harry's two best
friends hermione is the highly
intelligent muggleborn witch who has a
reputation for her love of books and
academia after being sorted into
gryffindor alongside harry and ron
weasley
the three develop a close friendship
that only grows stronger as their years
together at hogwarts go on
throughout the series hermione spends
plenty of time in the weasley home along
with harry and is present during most of
harry's epic adventures
and while all of this may be true in
both the harry potter novels and films
there are actually many major
differences when it comes to this main
character's traits
naturally slight differences between a
character's physical appearance and
personality are to be expected when
translating a story from the page to the
screen it can be a difficult task indeed
to adapt the dynamic characteristics of
multiple beloved characters especially
when you're dealing with a lengthy
manuscript
for example what can be expanded on in
800 to 900 pages of a novel is
incredibly difficult to cram into the
confines of a two-hour movie version and
to that end i've often encouraged fans
of harry potter to
at least to some extent view the novels
in the films as two separate entities
yes of course they are both set in the
same wizarding world universe and yes
the main characters from the books are
present and accounted for in all of the
movies
but if you want the two stories to be
the exact same representations of each
other you will be sadly disappointed and
the depiction of individual characters
is no different however certain
liberties taken with the character of
miss hermione granger do bother me quite
a bit
no matter how i look at it
so with that in mind let's dig into some
of the key differences in hermione's
character portrayal between the novels
and the films
major difference number one her
appearance
so yes let's start off with one of the
most obvious differences between book
and movie hermione her physical
attributes in the novels especially in
the first few books we are often
reminded of hermione's large front teeth
and big frizzy hair
in fact her teeth are a topic of so much
discussion in the novels that when
they're shrunk down in the goblet of
fire ron and harry instantly notice
this happens after draco malfoy hexes
hermione using densorgio a spell which
elongates one's teeth at an alarming
rate
the incident sends her to hogwarts
hospital wing where hermione lets madame
pomfrey shrink her teeth down into a
size noticeably smaller than before in
the films hermione is portrayed by
actress emma watson who certainly isn't
awkward looking and her teeth are and
have always been well not large
this of course cannot really be helped
emma watson won the role and she did not
have big teeth and yet you may be
wondering since it was such a focal
point in the books why didn't they make
her wear fake teeth for the first few
films
well actually they tried according to an
interview that chris columbus director
of the first two harry potter films gave
to entertainment weekly they did attempt
to have emma wear a set of fake teeth to
better match the novel's description of
hermione however young emma found it
difficult to speak when wearing the
teeth so they decided to mix it fair
enough
in terms of her hair however i would
argue that as the films went on it got
substantially flatter and straighter
this definitely could have been helped
what started out as rather bushy in the
philosopher's stone was notably less so
by the chamber of secrets and what i'd
simply call wavy by the prisoner of
azkaban this i can only talk up to
hollywood leveraging emma watson's
natural good looks as she grew into a
young woman frizzy hair be gone
major difference number two her
muggleness
now in the books hermione and harry
often find themselves unaware of
wizarding world practices or cultural
differences from local society and ron
is frequently taking it upon himself to
educate them this makes sense since ron
was born into a wizarding family and
both hermione and harry grew up away
from the wizarding world in muggle homes
everything from reminding hermione that
she's a witch who doesn't need wood to
start a fire
to explaining the offensiveness of being
called a mudblood comes from ron the
trio's resident instructor on all things
magic in a cultural or societal sense in
other words pretty much everything about
the wizarding world that one could not
learn in a book
because of course hermione remains the
group's most studious member in terms of
academia in both the novels and the
films in just the movies however
hermione seems to be incredibly well
versed in all things magic from academic
learnings to wizard culture
and i must say i do take issue with this
difference
i've heard a few fans say that they
believe this modification came about due
to the film wanting to simplify who the
audience learned wizarding facts from
but quite honestly i just don't agree
that it makes sense to have a
muggle-born witch explaining things that
she would have had no experience with
and quite frankly no knowledge of what's
more by taking many of ron's more
prominent moments in which he explains
ways of the wizarding world to harry and
hermione
away from him in the films it really
doesn't leave him with much he becomes
somewhat of a goofy bumbling fool in the
movies something he is not in the books
and by contrast it makes hermione seem
almost unreal i mean who is this 11 year
old who knows everything about a world
she has only just discovered it makes
her rather unbelievable if you ask me
major difference number three her
character flaws
the final major difference between
hermione and the books versus the films
has to do with her character flaws or
lack thereof what i mean by this is that
in the harry potter novels hermione is
well flawed but in the movies she is
pretty well perfect
now in the novel series hermione
although brilliant is often portrayed as
panicky and fearful
in particular you may remember how
panicked she became in the scene
mentioned earlier from the philosopher's
stone in which she quite forgets that
she is a witch and can start fire
without matches and wood so although she
knows the element that is fire that
could save her ron and harry from the
devil's snare which they are trapped she
completely panics that they don't have
the materials to make it it's then ron
who points out to her that she has the
capabilities to create fire with magic
you then compare this moment to the
movie version in which hermione both
knows how to escape from the devil snare
and the spell to conjure it taking
charge to free them in terms of fear in
the books hermione is afraid of many
things this can be seen in her fear of
flying and how scared of voldemort she
is which is quite a normal thing
considering at the beginning of the
series she's a child
in the movies however we never really
hear much about hermione being afraid of
well anything
her fear of flying is not focused on
in fact in the movie it's actually
hermione who comes up with the trio's
escape plan from gringott's wizarding
bank in the deathly hallows
which in the book is a plan that belongs
to harry and hermione is so scared of
flying that she almost doesn't get on
the dragon another example of her fear
in the book which is absent in the films
is as i mentioned her fear of voldemort
in the novels she is among the majority
of witches and wizards who refuse to say
the darkhaul's name for fear of what he
represents and his infamous power in the
movies however she not only says
voldemort aloud she is given what is
actually albus dumbledore's line in the
books
fear of a name only increases fear of
the thing itself all this to say that by
removing some of these character flaws
of the novel version of hermione the
movie version of her is almost too
perfect she's no longer relatable rather
she's this beautiful incredibly
intelligent talented and resourceful
young woman who seems too good to hang
out even with the boy who lived in fact
i think that all three of these major
differences between book and film
hermione amount to the same thing
each alteration makes her less and less
relatable
what did you think do you agree
did the movie ruin hermione or improve
her let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel
until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live